sin duda el tema principal será el tema
migratorio se va a crear según autos
oficiales de la Casa Blanca un grupo de
trabajo para tratar el tema del trabajo
migratorio Es decir de los mexicanos que
quieren venir a hacer trabajos
temporales acá a Estados Unidos se
Tratará también el tema de la
infraestructura se quiere invertir aún
más en la frontera para mejorar los
puertos de entrada para tratar de
controlar el tráfico de fentanilo y para
trabajar en temas de energía verde y
cambio climático que le interesa mucho a
Estados Unidos pero que no ha visto la
misma respuesta por parte de el gobierno
mexicano la reunión bilateral será las
11:15 de la mañana amlo previamente ha
tenido reuniones con otros oficiales
estadounidenses incluyendo la
vicepresidenta kamala James ahora
Cristóbal también como ya lo sabemos
digamos la relación entre Estados Unidos
y México viene siendo tensa No desde la
administración del ex presidente Donald
Trump sin embargo son los principales
socios comerciales Cómo se explica esta
doble retórica
ese precisamente eso ese retórica
retórica que mandatarios sobre todo los
últimos días hablo ha usado para pues
tratar de marcar distancia sin embargo
esta relación es bastante fuerte y
sistólica es la relación comercial más
grande que tiene México Obviamente con
Estados Unidos y pues sí anteriormente
Donald Trump le había pedido a amlo que
por favor se enfocar únicamente en
evitar que migrantes llegaran a la
frontera del sur pero ahora la
administración de está ampliando un poco
más ese panorama de temas para tratar de
forma bilateral y le ha pedido a México
precisamente más acción en cuanto al
cambio climático más acción en cuanto a
derechos humanos y más acción en cuanto
a pues tratar de controlar el tema de
los Derechos Humanos en la frontera
norte la frontera de Estados Unidos y